coca-cola has launched a Ramadan version
of its products in Norway the logo
features the crescent moon to celebrate
the Muslim holy month although not
everybody has welcomed the idea shame on
you for promoting women oppressing
homosexuals terrorizing Islam did he
also make adverts with a cross in Saudi
Arabia Easter this is getting too stupid
if your company is using the crescent
moon of Islam in Norway as a marketing
tool during Ramadan I will have no
choice but to boycott your products
according to the Pew Research Center the
number of Muslims in Norway's on the
rise in 2016 they represented almost six
percent of the population coca-cola
Norway has defended the Ramadan logo
saying it's part of the brand's
commitment to diversity and also
inclusion coca-cola has tried appealing
to Muslims in previous promo campaigns
in other countries
[Music]
for example last year it's Dutch wing
ran a Facebook advertisement in which a
Muslim woman gets a scornful look but
ends up making friends with a stranger
marketing expert Luc warlock thinks that
Muslim culture is being exploited by the
company to sell its product nori is a
very tolerant country for all kinds of
minorities and is very much respectful
of diversity so here in Norway it's more
like a public relations campaign rather
than a real advertising campaign I think
coca-cola wants to make a statement that
they value diversity that they think of
that that they want to be part of an
inclusive society and of course they're
a commercial company they try to sell
coca-cola but also a madam itself is a
very family-oriented meaningful ritual
in in Islam so it's it's natural for
coca-cola to link to that and if there
are similar things in Buddhism or
Hinduism or whatever and there is a
sizable group of the population that
might respond to that then then I'm sure
coca-cola will do that too
you